A new trailer is out for Westworld Season
2, and it reveals lots about the character
arcs and themes of the new season, as well
as some glimpses at the deepest secrets of
Westworld.
Bernard wakes up on a beach with the sort
of hangover you can only get from finding
out that you’re a robot and your whole life
is a lie and also the sea’s full of corpses.
Bernard has some thinking to do.
Who is he now?
What does his life mean?
And after Dolores’ robot uprising, whose
side is he on?
Is he with his robot brethren?
Or with the humans he’s lived with all his
life?
We see Bernard with human security forces
including Charlotte, Stubbs, and new characters
Maling and Karl.
But Charlotte discovers a bunch of old Bernard
hosts.
How will she and the other humans react when
they find out that Bernard is a machine?
How can they trust him?
Dolores is enjoying her new freedom.
But she’s also waging a brutal war against
humans.
She captures and hangs people, she says it’s
a “reckoning”, justice for the terrible
things humans did to hosts . But it’s also
a fight for survival.
“It's us or them” she says.
With Dolores is her army of masked men, and
Clementine, and Teddy.
Teddy seems to be the angel on Dolores’
shoulder, politely suggesting that violent
genocide might not be the right thing to do.
“Is this really what you want?” he asks
. Dolores meets Maeve, and she also questions
Dolores – Maeve suggests that taking violent
revenge makes you just as bad as the humans
are .
Maeve’s goal is to reunite with her robot
daughter.
So she confronts Sizemore and demands that
he help her . Sizemore points out that Maeve’s
daughter is just a robot, a machine programmed
to play a role – it’s not really her daughter
. But Maeve wants her anyway.
Maybe the idea here is that the only meaning
in life is what we choose to value, so there’s
beauty in Maeve’s love for her daughter
even if it’s artificial.
We see Maeve in Shogun World, the Japanese-themed
Delos park.
Which is weird, because last season, Felix
said that Maeve’s daughter is in Park 1.
And on the Delos website, it looks like Westworld
is Park 1, not Shogun World – so why is
Maeve there?
Maybe the entrance to Westworld is locked
down, so Maeve has to take a detour through
Shogun World to get in.
Maybe she’ll also see some of the other
four parks.
Westworld security forces mop up what’s
left after Dolores’ massacre.
And later it looks like they get in a fight
with the Confederados, the ex-confederate
soldier hosts from last season.
Charlotte, meanwhile, has her own mission.
A video hidden on the Delos website shows
Charlotte’s name along with the words “Find
Peter Abernathy”.
Peter is the host who Charlotte tried to use
to smuggle data out of Westworld last season.
Her plan failed when Peter disappeared from
host cold storage.
It looks like now, Charlotte’s trying to
get him back.
So all of this stuff is happening in the present
of Westworld, but Season 2, like last season,
uses a non-linear timeline.
Some parts of the story are set decades in
the past.
So we see Dolores with Arnold, the original
human Bernard from thirty years ago.
And he tells her that dreams “don't mean
anything” – but Dolores doesn’t like
that answer . Maybe because, according to
Ford, “dreams mean everything” – they
represent the people “who we could become”
. So maybe Dolores is now angry that she was
held back from her destiny for so long.
We see Dolores after sex with Logan – it
looks like they’re both at this party or
corporate gig in some real world-looking city
– so this could be New York – or maybe
it’s another park, Futureworld or something.
We also see Logan naked in the desert.
Maybe this is what happened to Logan after
William tied him naked to a horse last season.
It looks like we’ll learn more about William
and Logan’s conflict, and how William took
over the Westworld corporation, Delos.
In the trailer, we see James Delos, the founder
of the company, walking angrily from Logan
– who is possibly James’ son.
James seems a complicated character, we see
him bloodied at a broken mirror in a hidden
video on the Westworld site.
And we see young William meeting Dolores.
But this isn’t the conscious humanlike Dolores
he fell in love with last season – this
Dolores looks wiped, and unconscious.
Maybe the pain of seeing the woman he loved
reduced to a machine is part of what led William
to become the Man in Black .
Last season, the Man in Black wanted the violence
in Westworld to become real and dangerous
and challenging – and now, he’s got his
wish . So why does he put a gun to his head,
and talk about burning it to the ground ? In
Season 1, Ford tells the story of a greyhound
that chases a cat.
When it catches and kills the cat, it gets
confused, and doesn’t know what to do next
. Maybe old William is the same.
He got what he wanted, so now he needs a new
purpose.
He might find purpose in a quest for the door.
Season 2 of Westworld is titled The Door,
and we see William approaching the entrance
of some bunker.
He’s also seen here with the broken body
of Robert, the robot version of young Ford.
And Robert appears in hidden video saying
“now you’re in my game.
And this game is find the door”.
Maybe this will be another cryptic quest to
keep William busy for another season.
Or maybe it’s a chance for him to break
out of his empty cycle of violence, and to
find new meaning in life.
Finally, we see more of these mysterious drone
hosts.
Showrunner Jonathan Nolan says they’re connected
to the Delos corporation’s “secret project”
in Westworld . Maybe this red technology stuff
is also involved – it sure looks like some
super important vibranium unobtanium special
nano stuff so… keep an eye on that.
[] But it’s anyone’s guess what exactly
Delos’s project is.
In the 1976 Westworld sequel Futureworld,
Delos makes robot clones to replace world
leaders and take over the world – so it
could be something like that.
Or maybe it’s a military technology thing.
Or human consciousness research.
In Season 1, Charlotte suggests it’s related
to the data hidden in Peter’s head, so maybe
her quest is key to Delos’ big secret.
So there’s a lot going on here.
Westworld continues to tell a complex non-linear
story, exploring identity, consciousness,
meaning on a backdrop splattered with violence
and sex.
This promises to be another intense season
of TV.
If you want more Alt Shift X videos on Westworld,
let us know in the comments, and make sure
to like and subscribe.
And if you wanna see the hidden extra Westworld
trailer footage, there are links in the description.
Thanks to the Patrons, including Olya Malov,
Aslam Nathoo, Wyndle Kinney, Leonardo Traverzo,
and akrispin.
Cheers.